with the I don't believe for a single
moment that any members of the Scottish
national party who are morons
believed that that double rapist was a
woman now I don't think anybody does the
rapists didn't believe he was a woman
his ex-wife didn't believe he was nobody
believes he's a woman the biologists
don't believe he's a woman you know he's
not a woman he's a he uh and so this
absurdity is played out to the detriment
of the SNP so we should obviously
welcome this story uh because it has
shown awoke agenda as being
uh an insane ideology a genuinely insane
ideology which
is very very easily
um
revealed to be to be that to be an act
of lunacy